hey everybody mr. Kogi here and I'm just
doing a little stay-at-home science
experiment with some stuff I have around
home and what I'm showing you here are
mung beans mu ng even if you've ever had
bean sprouts before well those are mung
beans and you can see they're real small
beans they're only about half a
centimeter in size but what's really
useful with mung beans is a big grow
pretty quickly within a couple of days
we should be able to see some growth
what we're gonna do is we're gonna grow
some mung beans and expose them to a
variety of different conditions so the
first thing I've done is I have a
basically just a Tupperware bowl filled
with some water and I've already taken
this other paper towel and I've already
dipped it into the water to get it moist
and get it wet and I'm gonna take these
five mung beans and just place them onto
the water dampened
paper towel and hopefully the water will
provide you know the water and the
moisture that they need to grow and I'm
gonna just fold the paper towel over the
top and to prevent the mung beans from
drying out I'm going to place them into
a sealed zip-lock storage bags plastic
sandwich bag here so I'm gonna stop
recording for a moment because I need
both my hands to do this so I'll be
right back okay so I just got done
placing the water dampened paper towel
with the mung beans trapped inside and
sealed it into a little sandwich bag and
so this is going to represent our
control group basically it's just five
monkeys on a water dampened paper towel
with the bag sealed so the paper towel
doesn't dry out and so all I'm gonna do
is place this into a dark cabinet in you
know somewhere in my home
every 48 hours we're going to check its
growth so I'm going to stop recording
right now and I'm going to move on to
some of the factors that we're going to
be experimenting with
okay so the first factor we are going to
expose are never a different set among
beans - it's gonna be coffee what effect
might coffee have on the growth of mung
beans so here I have five different mung
beans again you can see there are only
about a half a centimeter in size and
like the last time I have my container
of water here and I've already taken a
paper towel and dipped it into the paper
towel and I've moistened this paper
towel so I'm gonna take the mung beans
and just like we saw before I'm going to
place the mung beans onto this water
dampened paper towel so far my control
group the shaping up to look like my
experimental group now it's gonna differ
once I add the coffee so like I said I
like I did a moment ago I'm gonna fold
over the paper towel kind of trapping
the beans on the inside and I'm going to
place this water dampened paper towel
into a ziplock sandwich bag I'm gonna
pause and do that again because I need
both hands to do this so I'll be right
back okay so I've gone ahead and placed
these different mung beans until you're
into a storage sandwich bag now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna add coffee and so
I just brewed up a cup of coffee right
here and I've poured some of the coffee
into this smaller dispenser here and all
I'm gonna do is lift open the sandwich
bag see if I can do this with with only
one hand and I'm going to just pour the
coffee into the sandwich bag not easy to
do with overly one hand I'm sure this
makes for a captivating video to watch
can he do it
here we go okay so there we go I've
added the coffee to the inside and I'm
going to close up my sandwich bag and
there we go so now this is one of the
factors that we are going to compare to
our control group so wipe the control
group a few moments earlier I'm going to
simply place this into a storage
cupboard and we'll check its growth
every probably 48 hours well what's the
next next factor we're going to
experiment with
okay so the next variable we are going
to experiment with it is a cold
temperature and again I've got five mung
beans you can see again they're about
only a half a centimeter in size and I
have my container of water here and I've
already dipped this paper towel into the
water and so I'm just going to transfer
the five mung beans onto my water
dampened paper towel like I've done in
the control group a moment earlier and
like I did with the coffee group a
moment earlier as well so the five beans
are on the paper towel and I'm going to
fold over the top again Pat it down and
that'll help to trap the beans in there
so like if I pick them up they don't
follow you know in my kitchen floor
so like I've done before I'm going in to
pause in a moment and put this water
dampened paper towel into a sandwich
baggie I'll be right back okay so now
that the paper towel with the five mung
beans is trapped inside of the sandwich
bag I'm going to store this in one of my
drawers in the refrigerator and the cold
temperature we'll see if that affects
the growth of the mung beans and just
like the coffee beans and just like the
control experiment well we'll check for
growth about every 48 hours so what's
the next factor we're going to
experiment with
okay so the next factor we are gonna
grow some mung beans in it is diet cola
and I'm sure for copyright reasons I'm
not allowed to show you a picture of the
can that and the brand of soda that I
actually used but in my little container
here here is some guy called well that I
had a can of it home now when I look at
the mung beans again you can see that
yeah those there's five of them and
again just like all the others they're
about a half a centimeter in size again
in my container of water
I've already dampened a paper towel so
I'm gonna transfer these five mung beans
onto this water dampened paper towel and
like you've seen me do with the others
I'll fold over the paper towel trapping
the mung beans on the inside so there
are the mung beans I'm going to fold
over the paper towel Pat it down a
little bit and you can see the timeline
beans are kind of trapped on the inside
so I'm going to put this paper towel
into a ziplock sandwich bag so I'll be
right back okay so now that I've placed
the sandwich bag with the mung beans
into nice and now that I placed the
paper towel with the mung beans into the
sandwich bag I'm going to pour a diet
cola into and on top of the mung beans
and sandwich bag again I'm trying to do
this one-handed so sorry if my fingers
are getting in front of the camera I'm
sure it's not most joyous viewing
experience but doing the best we can
okay there we go
and I can take with my free hand I can
take my container of diet cola import
onto and I can now go ahead and seal the
sandwich bag seal the sandwich bag
and like the coffee example from a few
moments earlier and like the control
example from a few moments earlier I'm
gonna put this in a dark location and
about 48 hours from now we'll check its
growth there's one more factor we're
gonna set up so I'll be right back
okay so the final factor we are gonna
expose the mung beans to is gin alcohol
so like we've seen before here are the
five mung beans and you can see they're
about a half a centimeter in size and I
have my container of water and my water
dampened paper towel so I'm gonna
transfer the five mung beans like you've
seen me do before now several times I'm
gonna transfer them to the water
dampened paper towel and like you see me
do I'm gonna just fold the paper towel
over the top trapping the money beans on
the inside and I'm going to put this
damp paper towel into a sandwich baggie
I'll be right back
okay so I've now placed the sandwich pad
with the five mung bean have now placed
the paper towel with v.5 mung beans into
the sandwich bag and I'm gonna add in my
container here I have a little bit of
gin alcohol and again I'm going to make
the best of the bad situation here I'm
going to try to hold the camera with one
hand and with my friend I'm going to try
to pour there we go the gym alcohol onto
the paper towel here we go okay and so
now I can go ahead and seal seal the
sandwich bag make it airtight as best as
possible that way the paper towel does
not dry out and I can go ahead and store
this in one of the cupboards in my home
along with the control group and the
coffee group and the diet cola group and
then in the refrigerator let's not
forget I also have the cold temperature
group so about every two days or every
48 hours we're gonna check for growth so
I'm gonna stop for now and in two days
from now 48 hours from now
I'll pick up where we left off okay
everybody so here's where we stand two
days have now passed I've opened up the
Ziploc sandwich bag
he's taking the mung beans out and taken
various pictures and we're gonna talk
about those pictures right now so here
we have again this is day two
forty-eight hours have passed I have the
control group beans on the left next to
the beans exposed to coffee on the right
and first question I'm gonna ask is are
the beans beginning to germinate are the
beginning to sprout let's look at the
control beans on the left you can see
yes bean number one there's a little
sprout coming out bean number two yes
you can see the sprout is about maybe a
centimeter or centimeter and a half bean
number 3 yes it's germinating you can
see the sprout again maybe a centimeter
centimeter and a half B number four it's
hard to see because the sprout it's just
a little tip but it's coming upward at
the camera so it's a little hard to see
but yes it is beginning to sprout and
germinate same with bean number five
there's a sprout beginning to form well
let's compare that on the right now
let's look at the beans exposed to
coffee know this bean is not beginning
to germinate be number one be number two
is it beginning to germinate no being
number three is it beginning to
germinate or beginning to sprout and no
no signs of a sprout forming be number
four
no bean number five yeah you can see
there's a little sprout right there so
one out of the five coffee beans has
begun to germinate but five out of the
five control beans have B has begun to
germinate okay let's continue well we
still have the control beans on the left
here but now I have the beans exposed to
a cold temperature these beans again
were placed in the refrigerator and it's
been two days since they've been set up
so they've been exposed to cold
temperature for two days are they
beginning to germinate you can see it's
pretty obvious there's no sprout forming
on being one no sprout forming on being
two being three is showing no signs of
germinating bean four is not germinating
being five is not chairman
so you can see there's a little bit of a
difference here between the beans
exposed to a cold temperature and the
beans of the control group on the left
okay well here's the next group of beans
these are the beans that were exposed to
diet cola and again 48 hours has passed
past hour is their signs of germination
yes you can see a little sprout forming
on being number one yes you can see a
little sprout forming on being number
two bean number three it's hard to see
but there is a little sprout again it's
kind of coming upwards at the camera
being number four no there's no
germination there's no sprout forming
and being number five no there's no
germination
there's no sprout for me okay well
here's the next group of beans again we
have the control beans on the left but
on the right are the five mung beans
exposed to gin alcohol and it's been two
days 48 hours have passed and let's see
is there any signs of germination you
can see it's pretty obvious being one no
signs of germination there's no sprout
forming bean - no being three no being
four no being five no so we have no
signs of germination from the five beans
exposed to gin alcohol okay so now it's
been four days four days have passed and
I've reopened the sandwich bags and done
another series of observations and let
me show you what we found
okay on the left are the five mung beans
of the control group these mung beans
were basically exposed to water they
were placed and wrapped in a water
dampened paper towel now again the first
question I'm gonna ask is are the mung
beans at least germinating are they
beginning to sprout be number one from
top to bottom yes you can see a pretty
long sprout of little over three
centimeters being number two yes you can
see the sprout maybe one and a half
centimeters being number three yes you
can see maybe three three and
centimetres being number 4 yes it's
beginning to germinate and sprout maybe
one and a half to two centimeters and at
the bottom even though it's sort of a
curled yes you can see a little sprout
beginning to form so all five beans of
the mung bean of five beans of the
control group have begun to sprout and
germinate and are beginning to grow now
let's compare that with the coffee beans
on the right on the right have the
coffee beans been exposed to coffee for
four days now are the beginning to
germinate be number one yes you can see
a little sprout forming maybe about one
one centimeter in length bean number two
no no sprout no germination beam number
three no bean for no mean five no so you
can see a pretty obvious difference
between the control group on the left
and the coffee group are the right well
we still have the control group on the
Left four days have passed but these on
the right these are the five mung beans
exposed to cold temperature these five
mung beans were placed in my
refrigerator and let me ask are they
beginning to germinate and sprout
you can see no for all five of them
there's no signs of growth in
germination and that's a pretty obvious
difference compared to the control beans
on the Left well again the control beans
are still on the Left now these beans
right here are the the beans exposed to
diet cola and so are they beginning to
germinate and sprout yes be number one
you can see a sprout beginning to form
be number two yes you can see a pretty
obvious sprout maybe a centimeter in
size B number three it's big it's curled
but yes you can see a small a small
sprout beginning to form
being number four yes there's a small
sprout there as well now B number five
no there's no sprout beginning to form
so the diet cola beans are beginning to
germinate now is their growth equal to
the control beans on the left no not at
all
but they are beginning to germinate well
see what happens day six in a little bit
and here we have again the control beans
on the left and on the right are the
mungbeans exposed to gin alcohol four
days have passed are there signs of
germination you can see it's a pretty
obvious no all the beans of the gin
alcohol group are showing no growth no
signs of germination pretty obvious
difference compared to the control beans
on the left okay so now six days have
passed again after a day four I put them
back into their sandwich bag and back
into my storage cupboards
but now six days have passed I've opened
up the the napkins and paper towels and
I've taken pictures and let me show you
what I found here on the left are the
control beans these are the beans that
were just placed on a water dampened
paper towel are the mung beans sprouting
and germinating it's pretty obvious yes
you can see be number one if I were to
straighten that thing out maybe around
eight nine centimeters in length bean
number - yes it's beginning to germinate
maybe around four centimeters in length
being three yes it's germinating maybe
around two two and a half centimeters in
length same for bean number four maybe
around two centimeters in length and
bean number five yes it's sprouting in
Germany if I were to straighten it out
again maybe seven eight centimeters in
length compare that to the coffee beans
on the right are they beginning to
germinate nothing from being number one
nothing from being number two yes you
can see bean number three may be about a
centimeter a centimeter and a quarter
but that's about it being number four no
germination bean number five no
germination so after six days of growth
the coffee group on the right very
different than the control group on the
left well we still have the control
group on the left here but now we have
the five mung beans exposed to cold
temperatures again six days has passed
so are they beginning to germinate and
grow it's pretty obvious all five of the
mung beans have not begun to germinate
there's absolutely no growth and so
that's a pretty obvious difference
between the control group on the left
well now on the right we have the
five mung beans exposed to diet coke
again are the beans beginning to
germinate you can see they are yes be
number one if I were to straighten it
out maybe three and a half four
centimeters bean number two maybe around
three to three and a half centimeters
bean number three yes maybe one and a
half centimeters bean number four yes
maybe about one centimeter it's a little
curled and B number five is the smallest
one maybe only a half a centimeter three
quarters of a centimeter pretty small
but it is beginning to germinate now
when you compare them to the control
group on the left in both circumstances
all five mung beans have begun to
germinate but is the growth equal you
can see I think pretty obviously the
control beans on the Left are growing
better than the diet cola beans on the
right okay
so now we have the gin alcoholic beans
on the right hand side are they
beginning to germinate are they
beginning to sprout and grow you can see
it's pretty obvious all five beans
exposed to gin alcohol are showing no
signs of growth after six days and so
there we have this little experiment
here and so of course there's gonna be
some analysis questions to answer
momentarily I hope you found this
somewhat interesting